hey youtubers it's Charlie so Deadpool
just fired shots at Batman V Superman so
this is gonna be my reaction I'll
explain what's going on because once you
get into the issue there's so much more
stuff going on it gets so much better if
you guys didn't see Deadpool without
taking shots at Batman V Superman but it
really it wouldn't be a new week of
comics if Deadpool wasn't taking shots
at somebody so I'm gonna explain what's
going on and if you haven't been reading
it this is all part of spider-man and
Deadpool it's their new title it's
number six spider-man and Deadpool
number six so if you're not familiar
with these characters like obviously you
can see this is a mock-up of the Batman
V Superman poster but Nighthawk in
Hyperion are kind of like Marvel's
versions of Batman and Superman and yeah
it's really funny haha you know shots
taken everyone's taking shots at Batman
V Superman but it actually goes way
deeper than that and that says nothing
about what else is going on in the issue
the issue itself is Deadpool making fun
of himself for his own movie like
Deadpool gets word that they're making a
movie based on his life so the people
behind the movie convince him to help
make it so he goes to Hollywood with
spider-man and they use the whole issue
to roast all comic book movies in
general so the Batman V Superman shot
was really just part of it most of the
issue is Deadpool making fun of the
Deadpool movie the writers the producers
even Ryan Reynolds smug Hollywood pretty
boy why aren't we showing my butt more
in this film I really want to show my
butt so while this is going on Deadpool
is like standing in for Ryan Reynolds as
the stunt man in his own film just being
ridiculous and it turns out that the
other stunt man that convinced him to
help be in the movie is really trying to
kill him like he's secretly a super
villain but at the beginning of the
issue you just like a true Deadpool form
so this demands like no this is totally
not a trap I am totally a stunt man I'm
not a super villain at all so they crash
through all these movie sets while this
is happening they crash through a stage
where they're making a daredevil TV show
just making fun of the Netflix series
what are you blind they crashed through
a walking dead set you know called a
bunch of zombies coming out it's
Deadpool making fun of all the comic
book TV shows and movies so equal
opportunity offender it's a really good
issue if you're a fan of
behind-the-scenes stuff for movies and
TV shows you get to see the back lots
producers arguing about story points
then complaining
about logic not making sense just call
them zombies and in the end they
captured the villain in this animatronic
Tyrannosaurus Rex pull his mask off
scooby-style and it turns out it's Ryan
Reynolds so it gets super meta Ryan
Reynolds breaking the fourth ball in a
comic that's breaking the fourth ball
about the making of the actual Deadpool
movie which I guess if you're not used
to Deadpool this can seem kind of weird
but it's actually brilliant I totally
love it when Deadpool does stuff like
this he's one of the only characters
that can get away with it in the end we
find out that Deadpool you know gives
all these notes to the studio and the
producers and in the end they end up
making the Batman V Superman film the
Hyperion vs. Nighthawk film so Hollywood
in the comic ends up giving it to
Deadpool in the but he's like well at
least I got paid opens his paycheck and
he gets boned so it's just like oh damn
it and spider-mans like it that showbiz
so the issues not so much Deadpool
trolling Batman V Superman as it is
Deadpool trolling all of Hollywood but
let me know if you guys really like this
type of debt like this tongue-in-cheek
breaking the fourth wall super meta type
of storytelling as you can guess most of
the videos I do about movies TV shows
comic book things so natural like this
is a type of issue that I really like
but I think it only works when you do it
every once in a while and especially
with the case like Deadpool like the
story of them trying to make the movie
how Ryan Reynolds had to accidentally
leak the test footage there's actually
new evidence now that suggests that he
is the one that leaked that test footage
a couple years ago at Comic Con which I
totally buy because you know he's not
the most powerful actor producer in
Hollywood but usually you have to have a
lot of credence to get away with stuff
like that normally like if just any old
actor leaked test footage like that they
would be sued out of existence but when
you're that big usually it spins into
something bigger like the studio's like
oh there's all this interest maybe we
should check this movie out again make
it but as you can see in this issue they
make fun of that process like okay we're
going to make this but you don't get a
budget we don't have room for characters
all right well we'll stuff Colossus in
there the character Deadpool in the
comic is like but I barely ever talked
to Colossus in real life why would he be
in my movie it doesn't make any sense so
it's just beautiful it's just making fun
of the fact that they only have x-men
characters available to them and they
can't use any of the mainstream x-men
characters they can't use any of the
Marvel care
actors and in the end like the general
message that you take away from this
comic is is that when Deadpool gave the
notes to the studio the studio took the
lesson that they should go for heart our
super dark films which is actually
something that James Gunn was talking
about he's like I feel like people are
going to take away the wrong lesson from
the success of Deadpool in Hollywood
they're gonna think that it was
successful because it was hard are so
they got to bring out really dark gritty
superhero films and really like the
actual Deadpool movie in real life one
of the reasons why it was so successful
was because it gave us something that we
didn't have before like it was a very
different type of superhero film not
just because it was so hardcore
so there's actually surprisingly there's
like a whole lot of stuff going on in
this comic book a whole lot of
storytelling a whole lot of meta
commentary that's really how the
Deadpool character works when he's at
his best so this is actually probably
one of my favorite issues of Spider Man
a Deadpool so far now there are a lot of
great Deadpool comics but when you put
spider-man and Deadpool together it gets
really silly but this is a rare example
of some amazing trolling trolling
hollywood trolling himself trolling the
Deadpool movie trolling Ryan Reynolds
and trolling Batman V Superman so
high-fives all around if you guys
haven't seen it you should definitely
check it out like read the issue every
single page is overflowing with meta
commentary like I only like the stuff
that I talked about in this video is
probably just a fraction of it so let me
know in the comments do you guys want me
to do more Deadpool comic book videos
now there's a Deadpool movie stuff
that'll be happening later this year so
I'll do videos for that but let me know
if you want me to actually do Deadpool
comic book videos like deadpool and
spiderman Deadpool in his own title
Deadpool is actually funding one of the
Avengers teams right now in the comics
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything
there's actually a bunch of comic book
stuff happening this week the flash is
starting to film again that means the
rest of the comic book TV shows or
product filming - we've got Comic Con in
a couple weeks so I'll be talking more
and more about that people have started
to announce the footage that they're
bringing the Comic Con trailers we're
going to be seeing so I'll start doing
some videos for that real soon - so why
you guys wait for my next video to post
you can click here to learn all about
Squirrel Girl in the marvel movies
people want her in the movies probably
not going to happen because spider-man
is already filling her role and you can
click here to learn all about the flash
season 3 villain thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you